مشهد التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه يرافقهم
مازق متصاعد ايضا تواجهه حكومه نتنياهو
حيث يواصلوا عشرات الاف
المعارضينوا التظاهره في عده مدن للاسبوع
الثالث عشر على التوالي احتجاجا على مشروع
التعديلات القضائيه التي تتبناه الذي
تتبناه الحكومه حكومه اليمين بقياده
نتنياهو الاف تجمعوا في تل ابيب رافعين
الاعلام الاسرائيليه والشعارات مناهضه
لترياهو المتحالفين معه من اليمين المتطرف
في محاوله لتكثيف الضغط على الائتلاف
الحكومي حتى بعد اعلان نتنياهو الاثنين
الماضي تجميد المشروع والدخول في مفاوضات
مع المعارضه كما شهدت المظاهرات لاول مره
رفع اعلام الامريكيه بعد موقف الاداره
الامريكيه الذي اعتبر ضغطا على نتالياه
وهذه صور مباشره من تل ابيب حيث تجمع
الالاف من انصار المعارضه
والمحتاجين على تعديلات النظام القضائي
رغم تجميدها وينضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره احمد هزيم اذا تتواصل هذه
المظاهره معك الساعه الماضيه يريدون الغاء
التعديلات وليس تجميدها ما الجديد طوال
هذه الساعه
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء كما ذكرت مطالبهم هي الغاء هذا
المشروع برمته لانه يعتبرونه تحويلا
لبلادهم الى ديكتاتوريه وانهم هنا
يتظاهرون لارسال رسائل عده للائتلاف
الحاكم او حتى المعارضه التي تدخل الان في
المفاوضات تحت قبه الرئيس الاسرائيلي
للوصول الى حل وطن هؤلاء يريدون القول بان
غايتهم ليست حلا وسطا وامنا التغاضي
والعدول عن هذه التشريعات وهذا التغيير
القضائي اتبعنا لخطب عده يشبهون عمليه
التغيير القضائي التي يرغب فيها الائتلاف
بقياده
بحكم فراعنه مصر واستعبادهم حسب قولهم
لليهود بعد ذلك وانهم سيتحولون في هذه
الدوله ان نجح اليمين بتمرير مشروعه الى
عبيد في هذه الدوله تحت حكم اضطهاد ديني
هناك رساله اخرى ايضا ارادها هؤلاء ان
يوصلوها وهي رفع الاعلام الامريكيه في هذه
التظاهره امتنانا لموقف الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن او موقف الاداره الامريكيه بشكل
عام والذي كان ضاغطا على نتنياهو وكان له
دور فعال في قرار نتنياهو بتجميد والعدول
عن عن العدول عن هذه التشريعات هناك ايضا
بعض الرسائل ردا على اليمين اليمين
الاسرائيلي الذي تظاهره الخميس الماضي
بالقول باننا ايضا نحن كم كان صار
المعارضه موجودون على هذه الارض على هذه
الساحه عفوا موجودون ولا زالت مطالبنا
حاضره وانهم يدفعون باتجاه هذه المطالب
حتى تتحقق لهم او يتحقق لهم ما يريدون ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك احمد هزيم من تل ابيب